يوم جديد من ايام المونديال كان عنوانه
فرنسي انجليزيه المنتخبان اللذان ضرب
موعدا تاريخيا بينهما بعد تاهولهما لدور
الثمانيه بكاس العالم فرنسا اسقطت بولندا
بثلاثه اهداف لهدف واحد بعد مباراه
اسطوريه من نجمي الفريق اوليفيرجيرو
وكيليان مبابي في منتصر المنتخب
الانجليزيه على نظيره السنغالي بثلاثيه
نظيفه ليضمن مقعده في دوري الربع النهائي
منتظرا لقاء المنتخب الفرنسي في ذكريات
كاس الامم الاوروبيه عام 2004 ارقام
ومباريات والنقاءات الامس مع الزميل على
سرحان
العديد من الارقام والاحصائيات سجلت في
لقاء فرنسا وبولندا ولقاء انجلترا
والسنغال اللاعب الفرنسي اوليف جو اصبح
الهداف التاريخي لمنتخب بلاده بعد تسجيل
هدفه الثاني وال 50 متجاوزا النجمه
الفرنسي السابق تاريخ المدرب الفرنسي دادي
حقق انتصاره الثاني عشر كمدرب للديوك
الفرنسيه منذ كاس العالم عام
2014 ايضا حارس المنتخب الفرنسي
لعب مباراته الدوليه رقم
واثنتين واربعين وتعادل مع ليليان ترامب
بعدد المباريات اما المنتخب الانجليزي بعد
فوزه على السنغال حافظ على سجله المميز
امام المنتخبات الافريقيه بكاس العالم
باربعه انتصارات وثلاثه
مدرب انجليزي يصل ربع كاس العالم مرتين
بعد مواطنه الفرنسي عام
و1970 وايضا بوبي روبسون عام
1986 و 1990
[موسيقى]
من الجو حاليا
نايف يسعد صباحك اهلا بك منورنا صباح
العربيه اليوم يعني فوز فرنسي انجليزي على
حساب بولندا والسنغال تاهل الى الدور
الثمانيه حديثنا اكثر عن اجواء المباراه
امس
طبعا سهام اعاده ان يعشاق كره القدم
وخصوصا المتابعين كاس العالم لا يتممنون
ان يلتقي منتخبان بهذه القوه في الدول
الثمانيه يفضلون ان يكون في النصف النهايه
او في النهايه ولكن يعني الاقدار ساقتهم
ليلتقيها في دور الثمانيه المتابع
للموبايل للمباريات بالامس يعني كانت
النتائج متوقعه لا احد يستطيع ايقاف نجوم
المنتخب الفرنسي وفي المقابل ايضا انجلترا
دائما قوتها وشاهدناها بالامس كيف استطاعت
التغلب على همم السنغال همم قد يكون يعني
بالامس همم سهام همم يحقق ارقام مميزه
داخل الملعب وكثره ارقام نجوم عالميين وهو
ما زال في همم عمره 23 سنه ولكن في
المقابل هو همم يتم اختياره همم
ااا جائزه افضل لاعب ويتم ايضا ايقاع
الغرام الماليه عليه لانه يرفض همم اشهار
شعار الشركه فاعله لجائزه افضل لاعب ولكن
يعني الاتحاد الفرنسي ولاسباب شخصيه
واسباب اخلاقيه هو نفسه مثل كبير لاطفال
فرنسا واطفال العالم لذلك لا يريد ان يظهر
شعار الجائزه
والاتحاد الفرنسي يتعاطف مع اللاعب ويقف
معه ويقوم بدفع الغرامات التي يحفظ عليها
الى الان همم اخذ ثلاث مرات اللاعب
الفرنسي
كريستيانو رونالدو الامس
ارقام رونالدو في المونديال في جميع تاريخ
كاس العالم
تخطى اارقام كريستيانو
عادل ميسي وهو اقل عدد مشاركات ايضا هو
حقق كاس العالم الذي لم يحققها اللا
كرستيانو ولا ميسي اقامه التي حققها وهو
بعمر صغير تنبه عن نجم همم
عالمي ونجم سيكون يعني همم ذو شان كبير في
كره القدم العالميه في المقابل ايضا اليوم
يودع المونديال وجماهير المونديال استاد
900 او 74 سهام هذا الملعب للقصه مختلفه
هو تم انشاءه في بالقرب من ميناء الدوحه
تم الاستعانه باكثر من 19 او عفوا 974
حاويه همم اليوم تشهد مباراه البرازيل
وكوريا الجنوبيه وبعدها بالكامل سيتم
ازاله همم
اجزاء الى همم الدول الناميه لذلك ستكون
ذكرى مختلفه لجماهير البوازيل وكوريا
الجنوبيه سهام ايضا سهام كوريا الجنوبيه
سجلت او جماهير كوريا الجنوبيه سجلت يعني
همم رقم ملفت في ملاعب المونديال هناك
يعني توضع اجهزه استشعار
لاعلى جمهوره يصرخ المونديال
الجنوبيه البرنامج اشواق زادت من مده
المقابله فخذ راحتك
انه كانوا هم اعلى نسبه او اعلى رقم مسجل
في جميع مباريات المونديال من ناحيه
الصراخ وعلشان ما تزعل علينا اشواق يعني
هم شعب لطيفه غريبه ان هم سجلوا هذا هذا
يعني
هي المعجزات كثيره يعني ما نبغى نعيد
الحديث لكن البدايه كانت مع السعوديه
بعدين مع المنتخب المغربي المنتخب
الياباني والمنتخب
الكوريا الجنوبيه يعني نتائج دائما تسجل
مختلفه همم سهام ودائما تظهر ابطال او
يظهر ابطال جدد نتمنى ونتطلع همم لمباراه
المغرب غدا همم ان تظهر سهام وان يحقق
اسود الاطلس نتيجه ويتاهلوا الى دور
الثمانيه جميع العرب في الدوحه سهام ي-
يساندون منتخب المغرب تذاكر مباعه بالكامل
لا نريد
الاحداث لكن يعني الحديث قادنا الى
المنتخب الذي نفكر في دائما
المغرب شكرا